this is hard last time on abby's sibo
saga
[Music]
you're in peeling this never-ending
onion there's just so much to unpack and
none of it is black and white
oh my god these ones all okay i mean
there are so
many options recommended for sibo like
it's
i'm so frustrated as a little recap for
those late to the bacteria murder
mystery party
i have sibo which is small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth and i'm trying to
kill it off once and for all my first go
at this in early 2021 went well but
basically doing the breastfeeding safe
protocol just wasn't strong enough to
kill this off for good so now i'm going
all in with a protocol that's an
absolute death machine yeah i'm gonna
kill this mother and let me show you how
i'm gonna do it but first let me jump in
here and tell you about my sponsor
butcher box so as you guys know i'm not
a vegan myself but i fully respect those
of you who don't eat animal products so
if you are plant-based this message is
obviously not for you but my family does
eat a limited amount of meat mainly
poultry and fish but i do try to buy the
best quality i can afford so i actually
heard about butcher box here on youtube
and i was really excited to try it
myself when i got down to florida so
butcherbox sources exclusively from
farmers and fishermen who meet really
high standards for quality you get to
choose your box and delivery frequency
so you get exactly the amounts and the
products that you want and everything
gets shipped frozen so you can enjoy it
at your own pace they have tons of
options but everything is high quality
so 100 grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken crate free pork and wild caught
seafood and it's all at a truly
unbeatable price basically when i did
the math it was way cheaper than
sourcing everything individually from
local butchers and fish mongers in my
area not to mention it is much more
convenient to get it shipped to my door
without having to even think about it so
this month i got grass-fed filet mignon
which is a real special occasion meal
around here i mean we rarely eat steak
but when we do
this is the one i want plus i got
chicken breasts cod salmon fillets and
burgers and some breakfast sausage that
i know the kids are going to love if you
want to try butcher box for yourself
check out my link in the description
because new members receive two pounds
of ground beef three pounds of chicken
thighs and a three pound pork butt for
free in their first box that's seven
pounds for free but very quickly a big
disclaimer that my protocol is mine and
mine alone please do not attempt to
replicate this at all always speak to
your doctor and a dietitian about your
unique healthcare needs and if you're
dealing with sibo please seek out
individualized care what i am doing
personally could potentially be
dangerous for you also if you are new
here do not forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode
all right let me take you on my journey
which started with two and a half months
of pre-treatment using a biofilm
disruptor so this basically helps to
make it easier to eradicate that
stubborn bacteria
so
this is weird but i've been told that
the bismuth file complex try saying that
10 times fast um some of the potential
side effects are kind of like flu-like
symptoms and also just like new gi
symptoms like nausea vomiting diarrhea
constipation etc things that maybe
weren't present before are getting worse
now and
i'm feeling that i'm not feeling my best
like things that were not triggering for
me to before are now triggering so if i
were to even eat just like a little
piece of cauliflower like i feel like
i'm back in my like heyday of my ibs
symptoms so
not feeling that good and i also know
i'm in this for like two whole months so
just trying to take a day by day and pay
close attention to my symptoms log them
track them journal them just so i have a
better sense of what's kind of
triggering for me now and what i might
want to keep tabs on but yeah just keep
my eye on the prize for when i get to
start those antibiotics
could not come sooner so i'm trying to
do
some filming here and these pills like
wrecking my stomach i'm getting
new symptoms that i don't feel like i've
had since the very beginning but my
stomach was like grumbling the entire
few hours and i'd eaten like those were
not hunger grumbles those were like girl
you gotta get to the toilet grumbles you
know what i'm saying not the best kind
of grumbles because at least the hunger
grumbles mean meals are coming you know
something something good is gonna blend
in my mouth that's what she said
but anyways
yeah that pretty much sums it up that
sums up how i'm feeling right now
okay so i'm already a bit behind on my
crazy schedule here that i worked over
myself but i'm not gonna stress over it
because that is just the reality of my
life like all three boys schedules are
going to kind of be prioritized above
mine and i'm just gonna have to work
with what i got here so i'm not freaking
out about that but this is day one of oh
my god just dropped my antibiotic in my
oatmeal not sure that that was what they
meant by taking it with your breakfast
but
today is day one of my antibiotic and i
am having it with my breakfast like i
was just gonna say not necessarily in
the breakfast but with the breakfast i'm
having just an fyi i've got a protein
smoothie here
we have tons of hemp hearts like i don't
know at least a quarter cup probably big
glob of almond butter blueberries banana
spinach almond milk
yeah that's probably it in this one then
i did my famous protest protein oats
with whipped egg yolk egg whites um oats
obviously i did some beautiful
uh almond butter some strawberries and
then i've got two kiwis as well i need
to have a big breakfast
because i'm used to having like snacks
between my meals but i'm trying to
really space out my meals here to give
my migratory motor complex a little bit
of time to work yeah i'm procrastinating
if you can't tell because i'm a little
bit nervous i feel like i have been on
this journey for so long and i've been
on the bismathile complex for like 10
weeks that is 10 weeks of feeling like
absolute crap especially in the past two
weeks because i really upped the old
ante and i doubled my um
my prescription for that so i was taking
it twice a day so i've really been
feeling crappy and i'm just so worried
that
this isn't going to work this feels like
my last shot um but i'm going to give it
all i got and uh yeah
here's to
healing i'm going to wash her jail with
my a barrel gas which is also
to be taken with meal oh this stuff
tastes like ass
i actually have to make that face every
single time not good all right i'ma eat
much better
[Music]
so as i discussed in my last video the
goal here was to aim for a 12-hour fast
between like my bedtime snack and when i
have breakfast in the morning and that
just is to help give my my digestive
system kind of the best chance at
optimizing the migratory motor complex
which is often impaired in folks with
sibo now i knew that that was going to
be probably the hardest part of my
journey because i i'm just like a
snacker by nature especially
since i became a mom i wake up hungry i
wake up early very early uh five o'clock
or so and it's still like several hours
before the 12th hour mark so lo and
behold that's what happened uh this
morning i woke up very hungry ravenous
so to speak
and i was not going to make myself
miserable and starving and famished for
three hours until the clock magically
struck 12 hours
so i ate i had like a couple pieces of
fruit i had some eggs with my son i did
my thing but i'm not gonna make myself
crazy about this i'm not going to
interfere with my innate body trust that
i worked so hard on because honestly any
potential
uh benefit from an arbitrary 12-hour
fast is going to be quickly overshadowed
by
the stress that restricting or trying to
stick to these rules in a perfect way so
f the rules i'm going to do my best here
and i think what this means is that i
need to collect the data that i'm very
hungry in the morning and try to have a
bigger bedtime snack to really just help
myself get through the night um and if
it doesn't work i wake up hungry and i'm
gonna eat problem solved so while we're
pretty sure that meal spacing is
important for you know good digestion
for folks with sibo we're very sure that
making ourselves effing crazy over
sticking to arbitrary rules is
absolutely
not good for mental health and what's
not good for the mind is not good for
the gut so just some food for thought
all right a little tmi update for you
guys um it is day three of me taking the
antibiotics and i honestly feel like
crap which is totally worrying me
because when i did the rifaximin only
regimen i felt amazing again tmi but i
was having like chef's kiss
delicious bowel movements we should not
put the words delicious and bowel
movements
in a sentence but you know what i mean
it was amazing i never felt so good in
my whole life the other thing i remember
from my previous experience was that i
actually felt like i had a better
appetite like i had more room in my
belly because i wasn't so bloated this
time i have no appetite to eat i am
having violent trips to the washroom
we'll just say that i just kind of feel
gross like i just feel a little achy
like a little bit under the weather
i have no appetite i feel nauseous i
just don't feel good and i'm just
praying that this is a good thing and
not a sign that it's not working because
i am taking all the things i am doing
all the things
and it's still and if this doesn't work
in all honesty i'm probably just gonna
have to live with this because there's
no way in hell i'm gonna be able to do
the elemental diet i just know it so
let's just hope that this is part of the
process and i'm going to make it to the
other side
feeling like a mother effing rock star
here's hoping
that hurts
i feel so uncomfortably bloated right
now and it's like i honestly feel like
i'm pregnant i feel like i'm back to you
know five months pregnant or like first
trimester pregnancy where i'm hungry all
the time but then i feel too nauseous to
eat a lot of food
and all the foods that i actually want
to eat are like fruit and carbs and
bread and easy peasy stuff like cereal
and oatmeal and then anytime i do eat
even a small meal because that's like
all i can comfortably stomach i explode
and i feel uncomfortably full really
tight i have bad digestive
events let's just say so yeah the whole
cycle is not feeling good to me it is
not my day
um but i'm just kind of taking
oh my goodness
but i'm just trying to take some relief
in the knowledge that this is
short-lived it's a phase it's like two
weeks of hell and then i'll be on the
other side so yeah i'm just gonna have
to do my best to eat the most
nutrient-dense meals that i can stomach
so
i have just not been sleeping well since
starting this whole thing and i don't
know what the culprit is like i asked my
dietitian colleagues if there's any
particular supplements on my regimen
that could be potentially interfering
with my sleep or like excitatory or a
little stimulating and we haven't been
able to narrow it down so
it's possible it's just like kind of the
excitement of it all or just a kind of
anticipation or a little anxiety around
the experience that's making it harder
for me to wind down at night and get
those sleepy cues that i so desperately
need as an insomniac but yeah might just
have to be
part of the experience so i was gonna
make myself like a little protein
smoothie but i have to be honest i have
yet to find a protein powder that i
really love that's made with stevia i
don't know i just keep ordering them and
not really liking any of them so i
tried this one it's a little better um
still
don't love it so i'm kind of missing the
protein powder i was using um pez
science which i think is um splenda
sweetened which i am trying to cut back
on right now especially as i go through
this eradication face um but yeah these
just don't compare in delicious flavor
and texture
just saying if i'm not feeling excited
about a particular food even if i feel
like it's nutritious for me i just take
a pass so i think i'm taking a pass on
the protein smoothie today and we'll
find something else to eat that's how we
roll this is a super super simple
chicken noodle soup with lots of big
chunks of chicken in there and tons of
carrots and i just felt like peanut
butter toast that's just like what i'm
feeling so like high fiber high protein
bread lots of peanut butter and some
beautiful apples that we picked at the
orchard this week
so update um i feel like i'm turning a
little bit of a corner here like the
first week i
was kind of more constipated um and now
i might be having like the opposite
problem but also i feel a little bit
more like i'm kind of clearing things
out and
um i do feel less bloated i have more of
an appetite which is nice i don't feel
so like like i did when i was pregnant
uh p.s totally took a pregnancy test
because i was like what the [ __ ] um
because i was only craving things that i
want to eat when i was pregnant so i'm
pretty sure i ate like soup and toasted
peanut butter for lunch like most days
this week i really was turned off meat
but today i woke up and i was like i
actually feel like having a more
normal-ish size meal um and i think
we're gonna do a little date night
tonight so hopefully i can actually
enjoy that meal and not feel like i need
to kind of just have a bowl of soup and
call it a night hopefully we are on the
up
[Music]
so i'm not feeling great today not
feeling great at all um
and it's not like i over ate or anything
like i ate a normal amount for me uh
especially you know like when i go to a
restaurant maybe even a little bit less
but while i'm not explicitly following
any diet plan so it's not like i broke
any rules it's just i definitely ate a
few more irritating foods um for my body
that i'm well aware of of course
um like
brussels sprouts those crispy brussels
sprouts with the fried frizzled onions
on top and like the cheese sauce it is
my favorite dish in like the whole city
one of my favorite dishes in fact a lot
of their vegetable dishes at rasa are
some of my favorites in the city i can't
not order them um but yeah that's like
the definition of high fodmap i'm not
judging myself for it i'm not shaming
myself for it i am noting it i'm taking
it in as data that
yeah
cheese drowned brussels sprouts washed
down with a glass of pinot grigio might
not feel so great to me well on these
drugs so i'm just going to really like
follow my cues today i don't have a huge
appetite to eat i definitely feel quite
nauseous today um just because every
single time i take the neomycin i just
like get a wave of nausea so i'm having
lots of peppermint tea and ginger tea um
and just trying to eat what feels good
to me right now which is honestly just
like a lot of basic
carbs potato chips all the things that i
was craving when i was pregnant it's
given me a lot of like pregnancy ptsd
vibes like
constipated check uh nausea check uh
only want to eat potato chips check but
i'm again not judging myself for it i
know that this is a temporary phase and
if it's anything like pregnancy i'm
gonna get to the other side and be like
craving salad like it's nobody's
business so yeah i'm just gonna take
this day by day and uh feel this one out
but i am a little disappointed because i
have this amazing oh cheesecake cookie
cake thing in the fridge that i wanted
to serve with lunch um and i'm gonna
serve with lunch but i'm not sure if i'm
gonna feel up to eating it which is sad
because it is so delicious but again
tomorrow is going to be another
delicious day and i will enjoy it a lot
more than when i'm not feeling like crap
okay day 16 here um i finished the
neomycin and now i'm just taking the
rifaximin and the
supplements and
i have to be honest with you guys i feel
pretty defeated um today's not a good
day uh but basically i was really
expecting a similar uh symptom
outcome that i experienced when i just
did the rifaximin earlier on in the year
that is that i felt amazing like my
bloating went away i was having like the
most
perfect
chef's kiss style
uh bristol stool chart type three bowel
movements i know tmi instead this time
around i feel worse so i feel super
bloated i feel like kind of gassy and
i'm having like pain
um i had nausea earlier on but i'm
flip-flopping between kind of feeling
constipated versus having kind of loose
bowels it's bad and i spoke to my auntie
earlier on and she at first suggested
you know doesn't seem like this is
working so maybe we should abort mission
or the issue is that a lot of the
supplements or the compounding of all of
the supplements are kind of muddying the
waters um in terms of giving us a
symptomatic evidence that this protocol
is working so in other words it might
just be that some of these supplements
for me that you know i've got a very
sensitive tummy so it's possible that
some of the supplements are causing
loose bowels and that is kind of working
against the um fact the antibiotics are
causing better bowel movements so
they're kind of like working against
each other and then it's just hard to
know if it's even working which isn't
necessarily a bad thing in terms of the
outcome of the protocol in terms of like
the killing capacity of the protocol it
just means that you know i feel like
so i spoke to my colleague anya rosen
again and she made me feel so much
better because i really just felt like
so defeated over this whole thing
thinking that i did all this and it's
not working um and she suggested that i
you know come off of some of the
supplements that might be causing some
of these digestive issues so we can have
better evaluation of what's actually
going on and ultimately we don't know if
it worked until i test again so yeah
it's not that any of these supplements
like universally cause digestive
distress which seems like why would you
want to take those things when you're
trying to heal your gut but everyone's
gonna just react differently and this
just proves why it's so important to
work with an expert um to really help
guide you on this and also to check in
with them regularly to actually make
adjustments to make sure that the
protocol is actually working for you
because again everyone's going to react
differently and it's also proof that
more is not necessarily always better
and i say that all the time but you know
it might just be that in my first kick
at the can but i didn't have any
supplements really in the mix that that
just wasn't enough and then on the flip
side this time i kind of like went all
right now we're going to go all in and
it might just have been too much too
fast for my particular gut i mean i was
taking like a pretty heavy duty
antibiotic um i'm pretty sure most
people would feel like crap on that so
yes i was really trying to do my due
diligence this time and get all the
expert advice to really lean on all of
these amazing minds because again
there's no gold standard here every
professional has a different protocol
has a different um kind of set of
guidelines that works for them or that
they've seen work in clinical practice
but it might just be that it was too
much
of a good thing for me but i am just so
glad that i have really amazing people
here to help walk me through this
experimentation to really find that
sweet spot for me so
we're gonna see the rest of this
protocol out and just hope for the best
okay so
day
29 i think i have stopped counting but i
just finished my four weeks of rifaximin
of the antibiotics and i'm so glad that
i stuck it out there because there was
you know we were we were teetering with
the idea of me just like a boarding
mission because it didn't seem like it
was actually working but
i feel like i'm taking a turn here um
and basically tmi but my bowel movements
and my regularity is much better way
less gas and bloating it's not perfect
but i feel like i'm on the right track
so i'm just gonna keep doing what i'm
doing and move along in the protocol and
hope for the best so yeah i'm just kind
of hoping that all my consistency with
the meal spacing and the supplements is
actually working out for me and paying
off now i will say it's gotten a lot
easier for me admittedly at the start it
did take a lot of thinking because i was
used to kind of just like snacking all
the time honestly probably a little
mindlessly um because that's mom life
and things are always kind of finding
their way into my mouth
that's what she said so it did take me a
little bit of thought to also determine
okay if i want like four to five hours
between meals how much do i need to eat
in order to get to that next meal not
completely famished and ravenous so
there was some experimentation on you
know size of snacks types of snacks um
those kinds of things what felt good
what didn't and that's ultimately what
intuitive eating is about it's all about
collecting data and now i will say it is
so much more intuitive and natural
feeling and also i've never really been
like obsessive about it so i find that
like during the week you know we've got
a good routine in my house with my son
going to school and my other son has
like his nap and his meal routine and
and so as a result it's quite easy for
me to kind of stick to a general um
pattern of eating in the day and on the
weekends you know we go out with friends
or something on for brunch we might go
out for dinner so meal times are always
a little bit all over the place but i'm
not stressing over it like that is not
going to make or break my sibo routine
so i'm feeling good about this that it's
absolutely not controlling my life in
any kind of way and it's something that
i feel like i could keep up for life if
i had to so now i'm on like a management
protocol which i will have to talk about
in a whole other video along with my
results from my sibo test which i'm
gonna have to do another sibo breath
test in two weeks and then i'm also
going to do what they call a gi map test
just to rule out any other gi
disturbances that maybe were not
addressed through the sibo protocol i
know i know i better have the best
effing poops of my life after all of
this is said and done because i am
super tired of this
literally but i hope you guys will
follow along on this never-ending saga
journey with me and hopefully learn
something in the process you know one
thing that i've learned you know going
through this as like a sibo patient is
not unlike what i felt i learned and
experienced as an ivf patient and mom
and that is when i started ivf when i
started the whole process i thought well
you know this sucks that i have to do
this but you do ivf you're guaranteed a
baby no it is still an uphill battle a
huge uphill battle and the same goes for
the sibo thing you know i thought okay
well i take the antibiotics i cure my
sibo it's over all done bye bye no sibo
is still notoriously very hard to get
rid of permanently so this may be
something that i'm gonna have to kind of
keep on top of for life so i see this as
really a marathon not a sprint and i'm
gonna have to find ways to just be kind
to myself and patient to see this
process through so on that note folks i
hope you enjoyed this video definitely
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if there's any questions that you
want me to address in a future video
related to gut health or other gi issues
if you want to try out butcher box for
yourself check out my link in the
description because new members receive
two pounds of ground beef three pounds
of chicken thighs and a three pound pork
butt for free in their first box that's
seven pounds for free uh don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye